Democrat Party is the party of child  abuse it's the party that represents  grooming children and sexualizing them  in school teaching anti-white racism in  the terms of CRT education and genital  mutilation of kids kids that can't even  get a driver's license can't get a  tattoo and cannot vote how do you stand  there and represent the Democrat Party  as a father and do you believe in  genital mutilation of children under the  age of 18 and and these puberty blockers  that have severe Health consequences so  a really buzzword Q Anon Bingo there for  Marjorie Taylor green she sadly will  probably win and that says more about  the country than it does about Marcus  flowers who is an excellent candidate